my name is Larry Cornelia I'm the mayor
of circle Montana parceling 280 miles
from the Canadian border my name is
Ariel Jerusha and I am a member of the
Athabasca to flow on First Nation I look
at it as an opportunity for the area the
county the local businesses as
possibility of growth there will be the
two-year influx roughly of the ban camps
and the people working on the line which
will stimulate the girls for the smaller
businesses in town but it's the tax base
and after the pipeline goes through that
will raise tax dollars for the county
and a portion for the town of circle I
firmly stand behind the fact headline
should not be built government industry
like cetera it's just a highly important
but what it actually represents is the
continued acceptance of you know
bottom-of-the-barrel
industrial development of dirty oil
I believe the way things are being done
now is done by the companies in the most
safe environmentally friendly way in the
future there are going to be good things
too to drop the need for oil in this
country we can't just stop the wheel and
take off again we don't have the
technology to go we've seen is the
Ambassador forestation
as massive dewatering and remembers with
the destruction of critical habitats for
terrible sizes which are a part of our
cultural subsistence lifestyle we're
seeing rising hasted health impact this
is now being even more and more
documented port MacMurray's for Makai
and port ship wands are becoming
hotspots for cancer clusters and
respiratory diseases and autoimmune
diseases the environmental devastation
alluding to the devastation and the
annihilation of culture and identity
for a small town like circle may
actually be able to fix the streets up
do better maintenance off our employees
possible better wages and packages if
there won't be that many jobs I have
heard anywhere from five to twenty jobs
in our area we're not talking about
long-term jobs for thousands and
thousands of people that I think that's
the total long-term jobs but I think
he's known excel is something like a
couple dozen long-term jobs associated
with the pipeline it doesn't make sense
on an economic front it doesn't make
sense on a job trend and it surely
doesn't make sense on a climate and they
seem injustice
you